about to tell you something real painful
this really hurt me i'm gonna tell you
how much tax i paid when i bought this
house
[Music]
hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm a property investor and in this
video i'm going to tell you three ways
how you can save stamp duty tax believe
me you want to learn how to save on
stamp duty tax see if you pay too much
tax when you buy houses you're going to
end up getting penalised by the tax man
hmrc you know how much tax i paid when i
bought this house so we bought this
house couple months ago i paid 276
000 pounds in stamp duty tax
[Music]
i remember driving up on the way to the
house just after we bought it i said
maddie i said what was the stamp duty
tax on the property what was it again
she goes let me work it out she works
that she shows me we pull up in the
driveway um she says 276
[Music]
276 000 pounds in stamp duty tax
i'm thinking man
that's more money
than an average house to buy i'm just
like that's crazy and then i look up at
the house and i'm like actually you know
what it's all good because the thing is
we bought this house to live in so it's
kind of okay but if you're buying to
invest you want to be able to save stamp
duty tax best you can so i'm going to
give you the top three ways number one
if you buy a house that's unhabitable if
it's run down if it's got no hot water
if it's if it's if there's damp if
there's no central heating then guess
what you don't have to pay stamp duty
tax when you buy a house so that's
number one number two if you buy a house
like for instance when we bought the
castle i bought a castle very big castle
20 bedrooms however technically it was
multiple properties in one so we got
something called multiple
dwelling relief that brought our tax
bill down from 81 000 pounds
to
8 000 pounds so we saved 72 73 000
pounds tax just by knowing that i'll
tell you something this isn't a case of
oh well the solicitors will sort it out
the hmrc will work out you need to work
it out paying your stamp duty tax is the
same as when you pay a self-assessment
tax you need to work out what it is and
then you pay it and then if they want to
challenge it they can but ultimately you
need to know these hacks third way to
avoid paying which stamp duty tax this
is how you can get your stamp duty down
to 0.5 percent if you're buying a
property that's owned in a company
instead of buying the property you can
buy the company that owns the property
okay i'll say that again if you are
buying a property that's owned solely by
a company
ins and you should always inquire about
this before you buy the house
instead of buying the property from the
company you just buy the whole company
and then that way you'll get the house
inherited as part of the company this is
something i've done many many times
significantly reduces your stamp duty
tax i used to always have the attitude
of i don't worry about the tax i just
want to make money until i started
paying
seven figure tax bills and now i've kind
of become a little bit of a tax expert
so if you want to see more videos on tax
i mean i'm not qualified to give tax
advice i'm just telling you my
experiences
i'm very happy to do an interview with
my tax specialist if you want to see
that interview let me know in the
comments have a wonderful evening and
i'll see you next time
[Music]